Tucker Carlson now seems to be sucking
up to failed former president Donald
Trump
after the text messages were revealed in
which Tucker admits to hating Trump
passionately this is very interesting
and I want you to remember that the
number one priority there's really two
priorities for almost all in corporate
media priority number one is ratings and
priority number two is maintaining
access to the most powerful people you
can possibly maintain access to despite
the reality that Tucker Carlson hates
Trump quote passionately
he doesn't want to be on the outs if
Trump is again president of the United
States and so the day after his text
messages attacking Trump were leaked
Tucker Carlson goes on TV and talks
about all of the uh great ideas that
Donald Trump is now proposing take a
listen to this you wouldn't know it from
watching the news media but Donald Trump
is running for president again you know
right so first of all the media isn't
giving Trump enough attention but I'm in
prison first which of course their plan
um and he's saying things that are
really interesting Trump is saying
interesting things wait but you hate him
passionately and you think he's an idiot
rehashes at all in fact he's come out
with a bunch of proposals that were so
interesting that we thought we
bring them to you we've asked Fox's
Kevin Cork to bring us the story okay so
then he brings on Kevin Cork and if you
thought that Tucker was being sarcastic
because look I just told you what the
proposals are it includes flying cars if
you thought that Tucker was kidding he's
not this is a serious segment a good
idea often begins with a very single
thought sucker Kevin Cork thanks so much
or babies prettier buildings cleaner
parks those are achievable goals ones
would improve everyone's life
honestly Tucker is pretending like these
are reasonable and good ideas so this is
this is very overt Tucker now having to
suck up to Donald Trump and I don't know
what happened behind the scenes when
Tucker's text messages leaked saying he
hates Trump passionately it's completely
plausible that Tucker and his producer
and fox brass got together and said
listen
I get it you hate him I get it listen we
all hate him maybe was even said behind
the scenes but he could be the president
and we want to host a primary debate and
we want to host a presidential debate
and we can't have Trump furious with us
and he's increasingly furious with us so
you got to go and clean this up that's a
completely plausible conversation that
could have happened behind the scenes
these ideas nicer buildings and uh
flying cars and all this different stuff
if it were a Democrat that was proposing
this stuff Tucker Carlson would be doing
his Psychopathic laugh and talking about
how unreasonable and expensive and
unfair to the American taxpayer it would
be to pursue these ideas so don't fall
for it Tucker is trying to clean up his
mess it might actually work
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping